[Music]
rob zombie the director of the house of
a thousand corpses halloween and the
devil's rejection brings you the
greatest love story ever told
oh i i don't like the sound of that
the brain of a super genius transplanted
into the body of a perfect
physical specimen
i want a man that makes my blood run
cold
a man that every time he enters my crypt
it's like a steak through my dead black
heart
i can whip the upper humpy down in the
lamb oh no remember what happened last
time he was fatty
i'm gonna go
okay
i'm looking for a vision
a queen true love
what exactly do you want is herman
munster in there
i knew the moment i laid eyes on you
that you were special
i understand if you don't feel the same
i'm just a regular gal living a boring
normal life
if there's one thing i know is that the
rest of the world melts it away
as soon as you approach my life it seems
miss lily is truly in love oh come on
you know and i know that we gotta get
rid of that bozo herman munster
[Music]
greetings from transylvania
[Music]
that's a strange way of saying hello oh
i guess we're gonna have to get used to
it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you